most Americans say they have at least
one financial goal for this year a
recent survey found almost nine out of
10 people set a money goal for 2019 the
top priority it's a good one paying down
debt followed by better budgeting this
morning in our ion money series CBS News
business analyst Jill Schlesinger says
the start of spring is the perfect time
to clean not only our closet but your
finances Jill good morning good morning
let's start with with tax returns
because the IRS R has already processed
over 65 million returns so if you've got
a big refund or you owe a lot of money
why should you change your withholdings
well we want to change with holdings to
help your cash flow throughout the year
so remember when you got that big refund
that meant the IRS kept your money
throughout the year that may mean that
you were a bit tighter during the year
than you needed to
so I highly suggest that people go to
the IRS gov withholding calculator then
you see what's the proper amount you
kind of want to end up neutral not owing
but not getting a big refund adjust your
withholding at work if you're
self-employed you may want to adjust the
amount of money that you're sending on a
quarterly basis yeah and not to make ur
check and also be used though to pay
down debt oh yeah and so that first goal
is perfect by the way when people say
that because if you did get a big refund
try not to go out and spend it have a
nice dinner but then pay down the
outstanding debt cover what I like to
call the big three the debt the
emergency reserve fund which one we
always give short shrift to and maybe
you can make an IRA or a Roth IRA
contribution either of those things or
any of those things can really help
jumpstart your finances for 2019 I've
heard you say should your finances give
you joy or joy so you're saying that
when it comes to investing you should
think about instead you should
consolidate you were saying right I mean
because what happens is a lot of people
are switching jobs and that means you're
leading leaving these little orphan
accounts throughout your life so we want
to consolidate this not only does
consolidation help you better manage
your folio you can basically take an old
retirement plan and go to your current
retirement plan or if you're maybe
you're self-employed now you start your
own retirement plan or usually you have
to roll it into a set and you can or you
can roll it into an IRA
or and if you want if it's a Roth kind
of retirement account a Roth IRA all
these things great by the way
it's also great to consolidate lots of
different bank accounts because people
are paying fees for these different
accounts you push it all into one
account you might get a better deal and
pay fewer fees to get the things that
you want out of your bank
how about consolidating documents
whether it's bills or statements a lot
of people are worried about throwing
something away because they may need it
later
how long can we keep it yeah fire up
your shredder because we want you to get
rid of old stuff now here's the problem
for the IRS they usually will audit
within say three years but they have up
to six years if you have a big error so
keep the tax documents for six years
hopefully you have them electronically
it doesn't sound like spring clean I
know well you got it but if you get
audited you'll be happy okay investment
says investment accounts for a year
credit card accounts utility bills after
45 days unless you need them for tax
purposes shred them get rid of them pay
electronically fire up that shredder yet
go well thank you